retour aujourd'hui avec un reportage de
1994 sur l'âge d'or d'une industrie
méconnu dans l'ouest canadien lui rinne
de jumeaux en gestation étaient utilisés
pour fabriquer à grande échelle un
médicament le pré marins destinés aux
femmes ménopausées et d écurie entière
était consacrée à cette production
[Musique]
voilà des hommes heureux le père et ses
quatre fils que l'amour des chevaux
réuni presque chaque jour ils habitent
tous les uns près des autres à
saint-alphonse à l'ouest de winnipeg
les faits sont passé leur enfance avec
les chevaux du père denis conrad
ils ont tous aujourd'hui les leurs au
total 75 étalons mais surtout plus de
400 grosse jument les flancs de toutes
ces juments palpite de vie elles sont
pleines et mettront bas dans deux mois
mais ce n'est pas tellement pour ce que
contient leur utérus qu on les bichonne
mais bien un avantage pour ceux qui
s'accumulent dans leur vessie c'est de
l'or liquide littéralement que ces
juments pis chaque jour pendant six des
onze mois de leur gestation la moindre
goutte d'uriné minutieusement recueilli
comme ça dure in tongues là dedans
lada lsl les selles un pion aux pattes
de chez les petits fils de monsieur
conrad ramasse quotidiennement avec leur
père la précieuse urines plus et sera
condensé mieux ça vaudra
car l'éleveur n'est pas payée sur la
quantité mais plutôt sur la qualité sans
galons d'urines brut doivent idéalement
contenir une once de renom estrogènes
la compagnie est heureuse qui achète
tout lu rinne déterminer elles-mêmes les
classes et les écarts de prix
le contenu de cette chaudière vaut plus
de 100 dollars
en 1994 toute la production du rin de
jument était concentrée dans les trois
provinces des prairies
près de 500 producteurs y élevait
quelques 65 mille jument mais cette
industrie avait ses détracteurs
les groupes de défense des animaux
s'insurgeait de voir beaucoup de
poulains et de pouliches prendre le
chemin de l'abattoir
tout comme les juments une fois arrivé à
la fin de leur vie productive en 2002 un
coup dur frappe cette industrie une
grande étude sur la santé des femmes
suggère que l' usage prolongé d'hormones
de remplacement comme le prix marin
pourrait avoir des effets nuisibles pour
le coeur
ces résultats seront nuancée par la
suite ce qui n'empêchera pas la demande
pour le rin de jument de chuter
brutalement du jour au lendemain des
dizaines de milliers de jument geste en
son temps trop sur les fermes
une catastrophe pour les éleveurs à la
fin de 2003 l'unique acheteur du rin de
jument au canada la société
pharmaceutique wyeth méfaits à des
centaines de contrats les revenus des
éleveurs sont amputés certains perdent
carrément leur gagne pain
au même moment une opération de
sauvegarde des juments se met en branle
jour et nuit
on les transporte par des températures
parfois glaciales car il faut faire vite
il y en a plus de 20000 à sauver la
plupart des chemins finira que par
d'engraissement ou à l'abattoir john
john bolton depuis des mois de sauver
ses cheveux elle en a plein les bras en
moins d'un mois nous devons prendre des
photos posséder tous les renseignements
sur les jugements les présenter sur le
site web les offrir en vente et les
envoyer à leurs nouveaux propriétaires
j'amène avons nous été aussi dépassé et
épuisés par l'ampleur de la tâche
au final différents refuges de la région
arriveront à rescapés plus d'un millier
de chevaux
plusieurs seront relocalisés au sud de
la frontière jusqu'en californie
aujourd'hui l'industrie de lurel de
jument gestantes au canada compte dix
neuf éleveurs qui élève environ 1000
chevaux en saskatchewan et au manitoba